every time we do something people don't  tell me you know hey that's a great idea  they say well how are you able to do  that because the assumption is that  these high and mighty do opolis that are  raping you for every penny you have if  they could do something nice for you  they would the hate you so music freedom  means that every single note from right  now starting with the top seven or eight  which account for eighty-five percent of  music will come free not against your  bucket and even when you exhaust your  high-speed data bucket you will still  stream music free at a high speed  t-mobile has far more network capacity  per customer than any other carrier